Dearly beloved, we are gathered here today to witness the union...
...of Mark Woodhouse and Pamela Mullin in holy matrimony.
If anyone can show just cause why they should not be lawfully joined...
...together, let them speak now or...
Wait!
Dad?
What are you doing?
There's a Pikachu here.
Catch it!
No, hey, this is our wedding.
Stop playing Pokemon Go.
I mean seriously, show some respect.
Are you playing too?
Nope, just speed-reading our vows.
Caught it!
I caught, caught our vows in my heart.
I'm sorry, where were we?
You've got to be kidding me.
I have serious FOMO.
Okay, everyone just put your phones away, please.
Let's proceed.
Who gives this woman to be married to this man?
I do.
It's a Mr. Mime!
Catch it!
What? No, I'm not a pokemon, stop trying to catch me.
Wait, no there really is a Mr. Mime here in the game.
Then catch it!
I caught it!
This is the best day of my life!